with great superpowers come great
superpower gestures a lot of them are
taken so how how did you come up with
you know did people talk it through with
you or did you just you know I was kind
of left to my own devices but I figured
you know everything looks quiet and
balletic and like a dance so I just
integrated the the twist the doorknob of
course that's my move is I just do this
[Music]
[Laughter]
for X the the magpie salute that's yours
sorry I'm like do you always me too it's
weird when I'm in a car with somebody
and they don't that well I'm saluting
them they're like yes yeah but to myself
sometimes as you do that one and maybe
you do the jazz jazz hands meets
constipated stance there is a big jazz
hands off you know yes but it's like
you're like holding a teacup and I'm
like yeah
[Laughter]
and Jessica you're new to this world so
who who are you you're not an ex person
I am NOT I play I play an otherworldly
creature some reason was told I'm not
allowed to say I play an alien but I
basically play an alien really tried
though I come to earth to try to take
this Dark Phoenix power for myself and
my own species force as one would yes
and in doing so I actually
unintentionally empower her mm-hm
but you've got jazz hands as well I do I
guess mine would be like working a
tablet because mine are super subtle and
James actually used to make fun of me
she's an alien you know just like a
little this and I remember the first
time James ever saw me do it I character
that went through all this rubble and I
looked over and I just went did you just
go like that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you